and the heresy were examining today is
that aid as it stands should be
abandoned and what would be the
consequence of that if we did so and let
me introduce the panel on my right is
Thomas and dictor and his worked
international development for almost
half the century he served as a senior
consultant to the World Bank of the
United Nations and numerous leading
global NGOs Hilary Ben was sector State
for International Development and
attorney Blair and Minister for the
environment under Gordon Brown Ronald
Maddox has been editor of Prospect
magazine since 2010 previously she
served as Washington bureau chief and us
editor at the Times and in 2008 she
published the book in defense of America
and on our left is Jan teller who's a
Danish novelist translated into 25
languages and format you and economist
in my almost 50-year long career in this
in this business I have been involved in
over 60 countries in implementing and
evaluating and designing literally
hundreds of projects last year by chance
I had a chance to visit a chicken
production project in Africa that was
the exact replica of the one I'd seen
fail in Morocco 50 years earlier same
stupid mistakes same lack of homework
and the same assumption that we know
what's best few months later I was in a
village in Zambia evaluating a water and
sanitation project and I spotted two
rusted hand pumps and I said what's the
story here and they said all those fan
club sets from Irish aid around 2003 and
what about this broken-down pit latrine
over here oh that's so let's see that's
Save the Children 1995 or so and here we
are putting in new hand pumps and new
pit latrines years later without any Pig
paying any attention to the obvious
archaeological evidence that those
previous projects has failed now why
does this keep happening and I can
assure you that it does keep happening
there are many reasons I'll go briefly
into only three of them right here the
first is that foreign aid for
development and I'm talking about
development not about saving lives and
not about humanitarian aid but about
development foreign aid for development
has become largely about the delivery of
money and things and that deliberately
delivery has been done far too rapidly
without enough homework and with a
tremendous amount of attention paid to
checking off boxes on a matrix that we
now at least in the u.s. called the
results framework did the community help
dig the pit latrine check yes for
community ownership was a local water
users Association form checked yes for
sustainability a second reason is that
our established aid system in my view
willfully ignores human nature most
particularly the fact that generally
people do not maintain things that they
received for free and more important the
third reason is that development aid
much of foreign aid has become an
industry an industry whose main purpose
in being is its own self perpetuation
there are thousands upon thousands
hundreds of thousands of people in the
north in the West like myself who are
employed in this industry and we don't
want to lose our jobs to justify that
self perpetuation in my view and my
experience the aid industry has not been
able to face its
lessons it has not been able to see all
the things that ought to have learned
over 50 60 years the principal one being
that development is not about money and
things it is about institutional change
and the complex interactions of
political economies social structure and
culture that inform those institutions
this level of complexity the current aid
establishment is not capable of taking
on board and so we are doomed in my view
to continually get it wrong who can get
it right well at this point after all
these years it has to be the countries
themselves it's really their
responsibility and our role in future if
we have one and we can answer that
question later it's certainly a
diminished one and we need to back off
let go and work ourselves out of a job
like Thomas you've described some bad
programs I can think of one the birthing
suite they've been provided by a donor
25 years earlier in a little village in
Ethiopia and they'd left and thought
right we got some modern kit here had he
ever been used to deliver a single baby
no why because there was no doctor no
Midwife in that community if you were
giving birth and your baby got into
difficulties you depended on someone
being able to put you on the back of a
motorbike to travel to the nearest
hospital now that is not an argument
against aid that's an argument against
doing things in the wrong way so that's
the first point I make secondly does aid
make a positive difference yes it does
because there are children in school
today because of the support of other
countries there are children who are not
dying of diseases that our children
don't die off because of vaccination
programs there are people who would have
died because they are HIV positive who
are not currently dead because we
developed anti retrovirals and we
provided a lot of finance the Global
Fund has raised a lot of finance to help
countries and I reflect on my experience
the first African country ever went to
was Malawi and at that time virtually no
one was on antiretroviral drugs that was
in 2002 and the vice-president just in
man away she was asking well what could
we do now that prevailing development
view at the time was nobody thinking
about anti retrovirals because until you
get a health service in place you can't
deliver them actually we were wrong he
was right I changed our policies the
Development Secretary when I went back
in 2006 there from memory there about
400,000 people alive on antiretroviral
drugs and Aid has played a part in
helping them now the progress we can see
more fewer kids not being in school
reduction in the proportion of people in
the world living below the absolute
poverty line reduction in the rate of
infection with malaria is partly a
result of development within countries
and partly a result of the assistance
and it's not aid cannot be the answer of
course not
because it aid was the answer if you
right a large enough check then you
could solve the problems of development
and poverty that is not the case
ultimately and I agree with you on this
Thomas it is about societies countries
developing them cells and that is about
the decisions you take for yourself not
having a a war is a really good idea if
you want to develop why did in my time
and why did Sierra Leone and Afghanistan
share the distinction of having the
highest rates of infant mortality in the
world well in part because of the
history of conflict allied with lack of
access to clean water and sanitation
which is the biggest killer of children
under the age of five apart from the
lack of care if they get into difficulty
just after they have been born it's
about having the rule of law good
governance good politics accountable
politicians all of the things that I
think our history teaches us helped to
make a difference the less spectacular
bits of aid for instance working to
improve the ability of a finance
ministry to actually shift the cash
they've got in their budget whether it's
cash the country itself has been able to
raise or budget support that's been
given by donors to actually get it out
so it could get spent on employing
doctors and nurses buying drugs building
schools buying tables and textbooks that
is less spectacular but in the end it
will make a difference people in eight
country a say show me how your aid is
making a difference I've paid the taxes
actually working together to cooperate
to give financial support to a ministry
that wants more kids into school but
lacks the cash is the most sensible
thing to do but it doesn't quite square
with donor country's desire to say well
there goes the British power ah that's
the vaccine it paid for oh that's the
kid that we are now supporting so we
have to work our way through that and
that is partly down to you so it's about
the right kind of aid in the right way
there are tensions and I'm sure we'll
discuss them about accountability to
donors because at the end politicians in
any country should be accountable to
their people not to me when I was the
international development secretary it's
not my job don't come and talk to me go
give your own government
hard time just as you managed to do to
us here in the UK and lastly it's both a
moral Crescent for me it's also about
our self-interest in the true sense of
the word not selfishness because in the
end a country a world in which there's
great gaps in poverty equality and
opportunity will not be a stable and
secure world and why do so many people
get in leaky boats and some of them
drown in order to try and get to Europe
from the coast of North Africa it's
because the life that they could see for
themselves where they live at the moment
isn't going to offer them something
better and they want to move as human
beings have always done to somewhere
else in the world where they can have a
better life and that is a really good
argument for priding help to support
people who in the end have to do it for
themselves
[Applause]